whenever you're at an institution of any
kind you're subject to the institution
its investors its donors I mean I've
been at the American Enterprise
Institute the Hoover institution it
always occurred to me that I have a
measure of Independence because when
you're in a think tank basically they
pay you to do whatever you want Tes
write books give speeches and so I was
like this is the best gig ever but I
realized well how does AI funded well
they're funded by corporations they're
funded by a handful of big donors you
you can't run a th those guys because
then there's someone to complain to and
if you become a liability they're going
to offload you I I do want to mention
cuz you know I see like super chats
where they're saying I'm with Candace on
this one I'm I'm like that's the beauty
of the daily wire though they've got you
choosing sides the daily wire or the
daily wire unless of course Candace does
quit and and and that would be I think
that would be like a nuclear bomb going
off for the daily wire if Candace
actually leaves I'm hoping that this is
just like kind of a half-thought stunt
of some sort